Traduttore: Elena P
Revisore: Elisabetta Siagri
Pensate a un robot che conoscete.
Forse, gli umanoidi
della Darpa Challenge,
la gara di robotica
più famosa al mondo.
È il top della tecnologia robotica
di oggi.
Ora pensate a un animale.
Il gatto di casa.
Qual è la prima differenza
che vi viene in mente?
Il robot è rigido.
Ora pensate a un polpo.
Non così.
So che siamo abituati a mangiarlo,
soprattutto a Livorno, dove vivo.
Questo polpo.
Che cos'ha di bellissimo,
agli occhi di un robotico?
Non ha niente di rigido.
Il suo corpo si deforma,
si adatta a spazi
anche molto piccoli rispetto
alle sue dimensioni.
Il braccio del polpo si flette
in ogni punto e in ogni direzione
e poi si allunga e si accorcia.
Questo per un robotico
è davvero difficile da immaginare.
Ma soprattutto, più importante,
il braccio del polpo si può irrigidire
in alcune parti, quando serve.
Diventa una specie
di scheletro modificabile.
E poi i polpi non sanno solo afferrare
e manipolare gli oggetti,
ma sanno anche camminare e nuotare,
tutte cose che ci interessano nei robot.
Le vogliamo vedere anche nei robot.
Si dice anche che i polpi
siano molto intelligenti,
anche i nostri, naturalmente,
hanno imparato a svitare i barattoli.
Ma non sarà questo corpo così particolare,
così speciale, a renderli intelligenti?
In effetti, la visione moderna
dell'intelligenza artificiale
sposta molto l'attenzione
dal cervello al corpo e ci dice
che non si può sviluppare l'intelligenza
solo con il cervello.
Serve anche un corpo, un corpo fisico
che interagisca con l'ambiente.
Ci dice anche che alcune azioni,
alcuni movimenti
non sono soltanto controllati
dal cervello, dal sistema nervoso,
ma, in qualche modo,
vengono eseguiti dal corpo stesso.
Come quando camminiamo
e il ginocchio ci aiuta a compensare
alcune asperità del terreno.
Ma qual è il segreto del corpo del polpo?
Il braccio del polpo ha molti muscoli
e quindi ci immaginiamo
che vengano controllati
dal sistema nervoso
per compiere i movimenti che vediamo.
Ma guardate cosa succede
a questo bracco di silicone,
soltanto un cono allungato.
Ha la stessa morfologia, però,
del braccio del polpo
e ha le stesse proprietà meccaniche,
la stessa densità e la stessa cedevolezza.
In acqua, che è il suo ambiente,
se applichiamo un'accelerazione alla base,
vediamo un movimento che è molto simile
a quello che l'animale fa
quando deve raggiungere un oggetto.
Ma allora, non sarà che anche il polpo
sfrutta questo movimento passivo
e non controlla completamente
questo movimento di reaching?
Qual è, appunto, il segreto
del corpo del polpo?
È questo.
È la struttura muscolare del braccio.
Si chiama "muscolar hydrostat".
Ci sono dei muscoli longitudinali,
trasversali, obliqui
e la combinazione delle contrazioni
di questi muscoli
origina tutti i movimenti
che osserviamo nell'animale.
Le contrazioni longitudinali ci danno
le flessioni in tutte le direzioni,
mentre l'allungamento si ottiene
contraendo i muscoli trasversali
con i longitudinali rilassati
che si lasciano allungare.
Così, viceversa, le contrazioni
dei longitudinali,
se i trasversali sono rilassati,
fanno accorciare il braccio.
Ma la cosa più importante
è che le co-contrazioni,
cioè le contrazioni simultanee,
fanno irrigidire il braccio.
È qui che diventa
uno scheletro modificabile.
Ecco allora che, cercando di imitare
la combinazione di queste contrazioni
trasversali e longitudinali,
si può costruire un braccio semplicissimo,
anche solo con un cono di silicone
e dei cavi all'interno,
che in acqua ha dei movimenti molto simili
a quelli che abbiamo osservato
negli animali.
Un vero e proprio muscolo artificiale
ancora non è stato inventato,
però ci sono dei materiali che hanno
delle proprietà interessanti.
Le leghe a memoria di forma
hanno la proprietà di tornare
a una forma originaria
quando vengono riscaldate.
Ecco allora che possiamo costruire
delle molle con questi materiali che,
quando vengono riscaldate
facendo passare una corrente,
si contraggono.
E così possiamo costruire
un vero e proprio
"Muscolar Hydrostat Robotico",
con contrazioni longitudinali
e trasversali.
E quindi, si può costruire
un intero braccio
che in acqua si flette
come il braccio del polpo
e si allunga anche, con le contrazioni
trasversali delle nostre molle.
In questo modo siamo riusciti a costruire
un vero e proprio polpo robotico,
imitando i vari meccanismi
di semplificazione
che si osservano nell'animale.
Anche la nuotata e la camminata sfruttano
l'interazione con l'acqua.
Per camminare il polpo usa
solo due braccia,
i posteriori, per spingersi avanti,
sfruttando l'acqua che lo sostiene.
E questo si può riprodurre in robotica,
per esempio con un solo motore
per braccio.
È una grossa semplificazione,
a patto, però,
che si imitino bene le proprietà
meccaniche del braccio.
E così si può realizzare un vero e proprio
polpo robotico con otto braccia
per fare che cosa?
Beh, si può anche immaginare di metterlo
al lavoro il nostro polpo robotico,
per esempio in mare,
visto che dal mare viene.
E quindi si può immaginare
un nuovo tipo di robot marini,
che, a differenza di quelli esistenti,
possono camminare sul fondale,
possono anche andare su una barriera
corallina, sono morbidi.
All'interno di un relitto.
Anche in medicina il polpo robotico
ha trovato applicazione.
Per costruire un endoscopio
che possa essere morbido
quando deve muoversi all'interno
del corpo umano,
ma poi irrigidirsi in parte quando deve
compiere delle operazioni.
Così come, sempre in ambito biomedico,
stiamo costruendo un braccio
che potrà aiutare gli anziani a lavarsi
sotto la doccia.
Ma il grande merito del polpo robotico,
e quello che il polpo ci ha insegnato,
è stato portare una piccola, grande
rivoluzione in robotica:
mettere in discussione le sue fondamenta
e dare vita a quella che,
a livello internazionale, è conosciuta
come la "soft robotics",
la robotica soft.
Oggi ci sono tantissimi gruppi di ricerca
in tutto il mondo,
nelle migliori università, che studiano
la soft robotics e sviluppano robot soft.
Il futuro della soft robotics?
Io spero che scompaia.
Non si parlerà più di robot "soft".
Sarà semplicemente il modo
di costruire robot nel futuro.
(Applausi)